seriously I will okay alright so who are
you why are you here my name is Andrew
harms and I'm here to make an appearance
on this podcast thank you for being here
thank you for having me
so do you think that in your comedy
scene is fair and just to a skill level
or do you think it's mostly about
intimidating enough people I don't think
it's about either of those I'm I don't
think it's a I don't think it's all
about skill level but I also don't think
it's just solely about intimidating
people I mean you gotta intimidate
people a little bit did it gets enough
on the skill side or do you think it
could be more I mean in a perfect world
it would be up all about skill you know
but it's it it's not all about that you
gotta is it unfair right now in New York
or would you say it's out of fair
balance I don't think it's that fair no
I
these are unfair I don't think I'm
struggling that's why it's unfair but
I'm I guess yeah but life life is not
fair no it's not but it could be you're
way more fair and I think people just
accept that it's unfair and then they
make it more unfair because they've
already accepted that it is unfair I
only understand that point of view but I
also have to I empathize with animals
there's also the point where it's like
you have to choose what you want to
change you know this is personal
motivations I mean you can't because you
can purchase isn't really like an
accurate view of what's happening but I
mean you can try to change somehow you
know be the change you want to see in
the world or you can just realize you
that certain evils you just have to
accept it more you can put your energy
into what you can control instead of
like closing your eyes to negative
things and be like everything's fine
well I admit shitty things when they're
around I think you can admit that or you
can't miss shitty things that's what I'm
trying to do and you're just trying to
like ray of sunshine Tim Robbins I know
I'm not I'm just might here's my point
is that it
you can only I might the point I'm
trying to make is yeah you can admit
there's shitty things but there's only
so much in your life that you can
control so you can try to make a
motivational battle or should we just
like accurately describe what's
happening in the world and then try to
talk about how that makes us feel yeah
yeah III feel very bad about what's
happening in the world I think it's very
unfair I feel like a bunch of like nerds
who got picked on got power in the
social scene they're like I want to
continue high school and punish the boys
or just put the stupid drama kids in
charge of the social group now it's our
turn and they're ruining it because
they're too petty and they're too much
like Trump
they just got power and they just use it
to fulfill their specific is there
someone specific you're talking about
cuz there's is there or is it just a
general it's a general feeling but there
are specific people it's just there are
a handful of specific people that annoy
me it's it's like when you try to pin it
down it scurries away yeah yeah I would
why how do I feel about it I mean I
guess it's um it's unfair I I think the
one thing that happening is there are a
lot of there are a lot of comedians you
know it's very competitive yeah so it's
it's it's it's not like there's only a
couple of it's not like there's only a
few fewer people where you you get it I
think it's more competitive so things
like networking and hustling and
fighting your way to stop top matter
more now than they might have but you
know you want to turn into that kind of
person and lose your artistic integrity
and try to find it later or which rather
maintain your artistic integrity and try
to make the social thing happen I I do
what I can you know I'm trying to do
what I can just what
I think I try to think positively as
opposed to work what you can do as
opposed to just complaining about I
think it's your oh yeah I understand
that I'd feel like a lot of people in
New York comedy they run shows to run
shows and they don't try to make it good
yeah it's just sort of an empty gesture
of a show and they just try to book
people that they think will book them
back
it's not about comedy it's about their
selfish desire to get ahead and I think
that's very trump like an American
well I I you see do you see comedians
that you see booked and you think oh why
is this person always booked this person
stinks you know like they shouldn't be
booked you know and but I I think I
understand I feel that way sometimes
you know yeah words it's like this
person's not great no this they're this
person is obvious but he's he's but in
in Alvin enquires defense he's a very
Asian you know yeah like he fits the you
know the problem with him is he fits the
stereotype - well yeah say like he's
like he has them so it's like insu
you can book album qui on one show and
that's like booking 20 Asians on your
show but he has enough diversity you
know he's a little Elvin qui goes a long
way
yeah yeah yeah we're just like you're
like you're like a certain like maybe a
good 15 oh yeah I say but I mean - and
then you also have to factor in that the
people in the people who put on shows I
don't like putting on a show no one's
doing it because they just want to have
a great they want to get themselves out
there you know what I mean it's not like
a producer of a comedy club which who's
like I want to just I wanna
I have an amazing show and make a lot of
money with all the people coming in and
spending money you know the the problem
of the comedians putting on the shows
they're producing the show but they also
want to get booked themselves you know
what I mean
so they're doing bid so they're working
in their own comedic self-interest more
than maybe a producer would you just
wants to have an amazing show its
incentives right right so that my
teachers at comedy clubs they [ __ ]
don't just do it for the money or they
wouldn't be any good at it it's a
shallow motivation they want a good show
cuz it feels good it brings a sense and
then people want I mean yeah it's just
like people maybe want to come back it's
like hey that was a we I mean other than
like me I think ya people be like hey
that was a great show let's come back
and that's even better for your career
that's selfishly concentrating on it is
stepping out and having a good show and
just putting your name on it that's like
that goes way further than like trying
to under handedly picture of yourself in
do jokes between every comedian that
[ __ ] doesn't work in the long run
mm-hmm so even if you're trying to do
that it doesn't work like it works for
like 1% of people like Trump's why do
you keep wanting them you keep bringing
up trouble because you want to I don't
want to talk about Trump this is a no
problem I'm not crazy about from you
love them you hate them you know the
hair the makeup it's just a ridiculous
person that's not more about the people
yeah I just I don't know I mean Kyle
shafted by the New York Comedy sing
you're being shapped I don't think I'm
being shafted I think I be but I almost
like I feel like and I think I should be
farther along but I also think that I
should be doing more for my own success
you know that's because
American Protestant and you hate
yourself and I wanna I feel like I like
I feel like I'm I need I feel like I
need to like make make things happen
yeah yeah III think that I think you do
need to make things happen all right
because I shouldn't have to you know but
you say you shouldn't have to this way
in a perfect in a perfect world lots of
no one you know perfect world we can
strive for something higher we can't
just be like this is what it is let's
just get used to this morality well
that's somewhere you're shooting for III
I mean I shouldn't have to but I don't
live in the world that should we don't
live in the world that should be we live
in what is then we know we can make this
world what we want to and we can't just
do it by putting our heads down and
staring at our belly buttons but looking
today you think I'm doing that you think
I'm just staring at my belly button I
think you're staying at your belly
button
you're like staring at the world as it
is and you're like let's just get really
used to this instead of creating your
own world it's not marijuana of a pen
it's the non marijuana vape
so em how are you
I feel like I just tried I mean it
should show business you know but I feel
like if you concentrate on that too much
than your art suffers on what I'm not
working and working and I want to ask
you this question do you ever see an
audience of people and think no matter
how funny I am I'll I my your point of
view can never know like my I can never
make these people laugh I will never
because whatever you however your point
of view your opinion your take on
everything is just not what these people
want you ever do you ever feel that way
because yeah that's it
point point of view you know I'm very
liberal and auntie fun and communist and
your your so I do feel that way but I
feel not that way a lot because people
want to like you if they're at a comedy
care they'd want this to be a good night
so they're trying to understand and they
understand that liberals are out there
it's not only my point of view they've
never you're like very like you know
it's not that just your liberal like
you're like socialist and very like you
know you're aggressive and it's very you
don't you don't try to sugarcoat it and
make it this kind of like your very your
point of view is very much you better
agree with me already or you know
there's no like hey regardless of where
do you think we like like regardless to
what you stand less you know there's one
thing meet you in the middle yeah yeah
you're not a meet you in the middle guy
you just like you coming with me or [ __ ]
you yeah I mean so yeah that does happen
a lot I'm either like 1 or 0 and very
binary there's no like gray area for my
sets mm-hmm
but I also think that give a wish right
of all my material I'm just a human and
I'm other likeable yeah he's of gray or
not so yeah I do
do you have a problem where you lose
audiences where it's like you say
something in your chest and they're just
like done with you for the rest of the
set yes like that point where you're
like oh that's where I lost them away
when you that when you lose them yeah
yeah because I feel like there's like
levels where it's like there's like I
always feel like I when I'm doing well I
would rather like I don't want to do
poorly you know I feel like doing well
and then bombing and losing them is
almost worse than just bombing the whole
time because like we they had you but
you raised them yeah they like they
hated you so much that you're doing well
in the beginning could it make up and
you see this as you see it in clubs and
stuff where it's like it's such a 10 you
in such a I don't wants it but like
fragile yeah if you think it is where
it's like it's like there and you think
that it's strong then you treat it
differently and they're with you and
they take their cues from you if you're
like oh I should have lost you you just
found me out this always happens I
always start bombing at this point
[Music]
anyways should I release this or should
I just cut this part out cut it out what
are you a parent on the subway of lower
income family yeah I just cuz I feel
like it I noticed this in clubs were
just like he's getting last he's getting
laughs uh-huh
I've noticed like a lot of it audience
just kind of laughs at the rhythm of it
you know what I mean that's well weird
like and then there's these like okay
but then it's like oh that was funny
that was funny they're like okay that
was just the rhythm that was just you
stop talking and you notice when the
last get like less strong and then once
there's that like once there's that and
then once is that point where it's just
silence
which is silence silence it's like good
luck you know what I mean yeah well I
think an audience would rather see a
person with good morals and a person
they like telling shitty jokes then like
a shitty person with bad morals telling
good jokes I see a lot of comedians I
that are like bad I've well III feel
like I'm a very difficult person to
please I'm not even saying that is like
a compliment to me like oh I know so
much about comedy what am I talking too
much a little bit all right we'll keep
on going really good interviewer by the
way hey is this your show on my show all
right shut the [ __ ] up I know I'm
interviewing you but I mean I feel like
when we're together there's just no one
to control our autism so it just sort of
goes it's all right man autistic scale
spectrum whoo-hoo flipper versus Free
Willy
I like Free Willy III could see that
what are you ask me Chappelle and what
about him that's what he's supposed to
do is make fun of me - he's a comedian a
comedian his job should be to make fun
of me - mm-hmm I just don't think he did
it in the best way I don't you don't
think his point of view was wrong I do
think it's point of yours wrong I think
he didn't get to that answer in the
right way I don't know what these
Netflix specials like I don't care I
don't I don't know I just feel I I mean
I feel like nobody has really cracked
the nut on anything you know they
haven't said something important yeah
there's nobody's been right I figured it
out you know like sorry I like the me
too
back in the day like specials they could
like change it yeah there's just so many
of them and none of the none of it is
that good so yeah they were the specials
were so spaced apart
did you ever watch like HBO specials
didn't it always seemed like those were
the [ __ ] best you know like those was
the best comedy yeah like but even like
films like Bill Maher and like Dana
Carvey and like yeah these Netflix
special I feel like nobody likes
crowning achievement anymore mm-hmm it's
more like you're part of the TV show
yeah yeah and not that people are so
janam I feel like people don't really
like anything well you just need like
five thousand ten thousand people to
like it yeah that's good enough I mean
what did you do something for ten
thousand people let me ask you this do
you feel like comedians get worse over
time or better over time I think they
get worse George Carlin he like sort of
puttered out at the end I liked his
Mittleman he had that weird middle like
just uncomfortable I feel like he was
sort of like his first George Carlin and
then super old George Carlin yeah
I didn't like that he he but he liked
you watch him now like his old guy stuff
is so vicious like you so mean you know
just like before like his earlier Jesus
Christ what okay let me finish the
sentence re let me finish one sentence
then you say a sentence alright I mean
that's what happens biologically is you
I'm sorry I'm sorry I interrupted you
how do you want to talk you just want to
like just have the loudest person talk
I'm sorry I you should be I'm sorry
[Laughter]
you're just so like you just like I
don't know why like you're just so
frustrated all the time you're in
chronic pain yeah you're like she's like
you're let you're like I'm like it's
like you're like shame time you know
because that's all I'm used to a shame
for my parents did your parents not love
you I would have loved you if I was your
dad if I was your dad I would have loved
you did the best I could
my emotions were mine to deal with so
did you have a sister yes I do sisters I
guess I spent a lot of time on a
computer so that's all yeah yeah we got
we I feel like both of us got weird I've
been on a computer all day vibe we're
just like the arched posture talking to
Jeff Greenspan in his apartment once you
need them for you all day
man are you I'm not gonna ask you
and you know what I heard about gay
people the best things that they don't
like straight people like they like gays
don't it's good posture hey I heard that
gays don't like they don't hang out with
people who are gay or something like
that like it's its own culture you know
like you got it like you got to be in
with them I don't know yeah it's like we
don't you feel like with every group
it's like this thing of like we support
each other we're like we're gonna be
like it's weird loyalty kind of thing
you know they don't make fun of Doland
don't screw he's one of us like I mean
if you can have that then you don't have
to expend as much energy and use it to
[ __ ] or whatever yeah oh man nothing I
mean that's like a strategy to cope with
life is to find a pack of animals and
just be get lots of that but that's our
natural identities we want to be
collective
yeah do you feel like women are like a
group are they like a loyalty thing or
do they not like each or they're both so
it do you have like a national identity
of like being a Korean person like these
are my people kind of thing yeah a
little bit much as other Koreans oh yeah
about more than Americans
I do do oh do you watch out like when
someone makes fun of light or like when
someone screws with a Chinese look
person yeah that's not yeah that's not
cool Dee are you do I feel like you have
a very Asian we're all Asian kind of
yeah yeah I do I put a lot of
different types of Asians hook up with
each other people of other races I mean
we'd rather stick to that's all about
that's how the organism survives if
you're just happy and okay with people
[ __ ] people that are not your race I
don't survive as a organ as a race it's
a natural mechanism it's like one of the
basic tenets of being a race i like
who's that chick so my yeah or like
something like like do you do you like
weren't you bond with like who are your
people who are your most bond like who
are your people
when anytime someone attacks them you're
like these are my people you know do not
attack these people students students do
you have that class thing where it's
like though the boomer screwed us over
kind of [ __ ] you know they screwed us
kids over do you ever have you ever you
have like I don't like when could like
generational hate you know like these
people are like these old people like
these gross don't you feel like we don't
like we win slates more like aging
hormone based and not like cultural
based it's just when you get old you get
like that however they are yeah I did I
feel like people we don't respect our
elders in society you know like like
we're like mommy daddy you know I think
do you think it's I think it's an
American thing to be obsessed with your
parents you know like that's such an
American like in my dad who's known for
his mother was anxious my mother
my mother was mother I would say and
then my father who's an alcoholic I
think that's a big thing is like my
parents were drunks and they didn't love
me or some [ __ ] like they had a hard
life
III had a mommy and daddy did you have a
mommy and a daddy yes
oh that's so cool that's oh we're so
healthy but we like I feel like we need
that in the nurturing you know what I
mean you know that's a it's important I
think I could have done with more oh
yeah I think I feel like you if you make
a cubicle worker they're not gonna be
happy people I think that lifestyle is
not great and I think if you have
miserable people raising children
they're gonna pass on like I mean if you
want like Joe Rogan yeah I feel like
you've ever people people analyze the
goofy like people analyze the cop
psychology too much like do you like I
feel like Scott psychology and like
therapy is this touchy-feely like it's
gonna be okay kind of thing is it really
even a science you know it's like too
soothing like just help me you know yeah
but it's all about you yeah and it's all
I feel like therapy it's like you're why
are you talking to somebody like he's
just gonna say what are you to say to
make you feel good you know what I mean
like the therapist wouldn't tell you
[ __ ] you didn't want to hear but still
or no score they would get make no money
she's just touching you where you want
to be that's all good
I feel I feel like I do how much
nurturing and comfort do you need I feel
like I need a lot like I feel like I
need too much comfort yeah it's such
it's like - I don't like I hate I hate
how like oh I need to be loved like like
everyone has to I have to be loved so
much like I can't just like I can't be
this lone person who's just like I don't
give a [ __ ] I'm you know what I mean
I can't be I I feel like it's all an act
you know when you feel that way then
you're trying to be like a yeah like
you're trying to be this like an adult
person you know yeah lucky you I feel I
feel like you need to make friends then
you can go everywhere with I feel like I
noticed
do you ever like notice yourself get
like like talk more adult as time like
hey that was like you yeah yeah because
yeah that's girl now now when you talk
like that people take you serious yeah
yeah I don't know what I I don't know
man you like the texture of the carpet
yeah it's so good yeah it's Scratchy
I think you would do far in comedy do
foreign I think you would go so far in
good but but what but you feel hey white
people too much I'm too much of a
communist I like what I like the hating
women [ __ ] you know that deserve it
hating women [ __ ] is out it's so flirty
it's like yeah but you like it's so like
it's like like you come and get it if
you want yeah yeah it's all like [ __ ]
girls you know like you know you like
you got a cigarette
no like you know it's too much
to actually not be balanced out yeah I
think it's gross when I see a man
expressing love you know like when he's
like Lennie loves his girlfriend that's
where you're bragging about what the
hell is wrong with you this is just why
you you're just trying to be like hey
baby this is how much I love you you
know yeah like this is all I can do for
you sign up now yeah it's an infomercial
for them to get people to [ __ ] them you
know I know a guy I want to be Gary
Coleman I want to be the guy with the
the kid you know like the single father
like like no coolest guy in the movie
there will be blood yeah like the like
flocks oh come on kid like I'm teaching
him all my ways he's gonna be like a
better me I'm a dynasty I'm gonna be
around for like you know anytime I see a
guy being like sweet to his kid like
he's like no come on creative human to
be nice to something but that was that I
think that's a sympathetic character in
society that single dad like come on
sweetie
it's not natural to me to be so nice but
like a single mom like a single mom is
like a person like a single mom is is is
what I normally see you know what I mean
that's the vanilla ice cream of single
thing yeah I just feel like when you
give birth to a baby it's just yours you
know what I mean you just get this bond
with it that the guy will never get you
know it's an unfair advantage I feel but
I feel bad for single moms hey I feel
they're always like they're so angry at
their children you know like imagine if
you yeah there's just like this I don't
think I could have power over a child
it's too much man
don't you think yes like to froze like
to really like like to keep it okay all
the time I that's true that's too much
for me but I wouldn't I wouldn't I would
get out of like endorphins and serotonin
mm-hmm
so that when you around your kid you
feel really happy and you wanna keep
doing that but I think your brain is
very fragile and if you had a kid your
head might xq this do you feel trapped I
feel fine
okay if do you think that if you would
be the kind of like the the big thing I
would see a lot is the man and the child
the man and the wife like getting
married like and then having the kids
but being divorced you know what I mean
it was like we didn't marriage and now
we're divorcing that's what you would
see yeah where would you see it just in
my own movies I'm in town and stuff
well that's 50% right yeah it's like
they're all like throwing their like
little detective like like you know it's
like hey let me speak to Bobby you know
I want to speak to like liar liar and
stuff yeah I would see that all the time
you know but that was the thing of like
that was like we're married but we hate
each other kind of stuff you know yeah
it's all like we have the worst
relationship but you know because the
whole points of those Everybody Loves
Raymond and those shows that I hate my
spouse yeah I think people that's why
they were popular is because it was like
they were just watched by these people
who like yeah she does that so yeah
people are not like that
and when you're like that it's so
relieving to have someone like that yeah
you just more attractive you're like a
loyal fan you get more loyal fans like
that if you tap into someone's dark side
I yeah and any really like like divorced
like it was like you get the kids this
weekend in a scandal and the chicken the
day you know like they're like soap
opera kind of stuff are we in this
hippie stage where we're just like I
hope so
like like like this unhappy work but
it's just go back to that monogamy is a
lie but everyone just hates it like it's
just so much there's so much hate like I
hate not do feel weird like when a woman
is like overly sexualized you ever feel
like when it's just like woman it's just
like why you why are you doing that you
know yeah this doesn't make sense it's
like you don't I don't I don't like it
cuz it's like it's it's too hot you know
I don't you know like yeah yes dick
neurons I can't take it
yeah I do feel like women should cover
up more you should change it's too
stimulating you know it's too late like
it gets in your face like it's just it's
too it's too much like it's distracting
I don't you know it's distract someone
talking to you about some nerdy [ __ ]
that you like but that's like to you
that be flirting but you just don't like
being hit on a certain way like you you
don't have to be hit on the same way as
everyone else you you have a unique
sexuality that I'm about to explore
right now
I don't like I don't like idea like did
you do is how you feel no you like so
you remotely relate to this artistic
expression yeah you'll do hate deed but
when you see a girl like and she's like
showing cleavage
do you favor feel like I don't like it's
tube like it's just like get it away you
know I'm in a social setting right now
it's just like it's too much power you
know we're like why you doing you had a
stop sign and you carried it like a
giant yeah it's like wings I like the I
like the idea of women keeping to
themselves more and being like you want
to put them in her jobs I I'm pro I got
that you know I want to drop some but is
yeah it's like women like I don't like
think I like women like he's like I
don't worry chasing my son you know I
feel like if you're in the office you
know what to wear you don't cause a
sting and it's a skill that they have
and some people are bad at it because
they're half the population some of them
are [ __ ] but and they wear like
[ __ ] you know the wrong [ __ ] at the
wrong time and they're blessed by God
and it's just all in your face and it's
unfortunate but I mean that's the thing
is they're half the populations let me
ask you this though let me ask you this
do you feel like women person purposely
dress a certain way to like like to make
guys go crazy for them like but it's
like it's like they're trying to seduce
us but they're also like like there's
thing like it's this teasing thing of
like no you know what I mean like yeah
it's like no objection they're like like
you like it not in a million years
yeah but they're like they want you to
feel pain
you know they want you to feel that like
like the frustration I give you what do
you do you know man today I mean I mean
I feel like back in the day like and the
boobs has changed you know the way
people yoga pants have taken over the
scene athleisure which I enjoy very much
I'm sorry
jeah do you feel like the way women like
the way women dress it's very like it's
like combination of the 60s mixed with
like the tightness of the yeah yeah it's
like everything like the [ __ ] legs
that are popping out of the [ __ ]
jeans these days bro like what it's like
I see them they're like yeah what it's
like right right close to the crotch
there's too much rule with you crunch
skin do you like it's just like it's
just like I can't contain it
what is it with this this ass is such a
weird thing cuz like asses is like an
allowed now you know because it doesn't
have that in that nipple it's just like
you can just sew all are very
conservative why and you want to not
playing explore that sexual part I think
it's gross I think it's too much for me
man like it's gross that it's like that
well like why are you being so disgust
like why it's it's like stop it so what
it'd be like is it's like they're out on
the street and some dude has like his
small intestines hanging out with some
guy had a broken leg and the bone was
sticking out oh I would be like that but
sexual like yeah I just don't like this
thing where it's always like where it's
just it just seems like it's too much
thing I have to think about - I wish I
didn't have to think about it a lot it's
like something that's always just in my
head constantly - shut up
I can't just be like I don't want it and
we reproduce sexually I I don't want to
do that
you know like I wish I could not a few
goes
as an exercise and discipline you get to
quiet your animal monkey nature and you
get to practice oh don't you always feel
like went like women like it's this
thing of like like ladies aren't
supposed to like you you know do you
ever feel that way you're a loser nerd
like it like it's like it's bad to [ __ ]
the chair like yeah like it's like it's
bad to be that you know that's what most
people yeah I don't like the feel like
the like the the like you're bad cuz
love like the D sexualization you know
what I mean
where's like being like a beast of yeah
you know yeah like straightness is this
like this is like the pursuit of trying
to hook up with the lady with sexual you
know girls remain the same but
culturally depends more on their job as
[ __ ] so our sexiness has dipped I think
cuz in the 50s you knew you'd have a job
and like a car at a time but nowadays
it's like you're a loser you don't have
a job you pee in a can do you ever feel
like there's this things like music do
you ever feel like there's this thing of
like of like being masculine that's very
taboo now like just being a guy's guy
where it's even like one he you know
there's no you have to be this I feel
like there's this culture now just being
this somewhat cool shiz and sorry I'm
sorry I mean
do you think that it's good to be super
masculine I I feel like there's a taboo
on it I feel like like that person isn't
isn't cool in society of being like I
don't know I think so I like that I why
are you protecting these people that
have always picked on you because I just
think it's I want to be that guy you
know yeah I'm always doing this like
anytime I'm around a lady I have to have
this odd impression of a man thing going
yeah like I always I always want to like
yell at them like be this flight gotta
be big I mean I can't I can't be I can't
I want to be like this this big person
you know yeah like this strong like hey
[Music]
you're the sexiest man do you feel like
you're too aggressive with them like you
don't just hear nothing most people
don't even want that was that most
people don't even want that if they saw
that they wouldn't want it like some of
the sexiest girls like Johnny Depp
looking dudes you know I don't think you
can't change biology that much do you
think women are like oh this guy's got a
lot of money do you think like I think
[Laughter]
do you try to do you try to be like a
guy ever I can't help it you know I'm
not ashamed I think that it is
uncomfortable that I find women
attractive I let them know that I find
them attractive and then I'm like okay
now I'll control myself
but that initial look I'm not gonna hide
anything
it's just like oh [ __ ] was that and I
think that makes it more on it so that
I'm not weird
so that I'm not being like you know half
in control and half animalistic like if
I just respond honestly and like oh [ __ ]
there's a hugger
I think that's fine I feel like I I feel
like I look at them too much you know
like I always want to make eye contact
you know where you're just saying it's
like once you get to be in the moment
and in the moment there's a hot girl
right there I always always like I wish
I could I don't know where you gotta
start neutering people like I feel like
I can talk with ladies in the eye like
talking you know but it just seems noise
in the eye we looked at each other so
[ __ ] hard that one night yeah but
doesn't always feel like in the movies
the guys were always making I like they
were it was always an eye contact it was
always like we like it like lady and the
guy would always be together you know
yeah that's you know like that was a big
thing back then well III I hate how it's
like I see I see too many women on the
train you know that's the only women
nice it's just like yeah they're always
on the train though I'm trying to like I
always have to try to find some area
where there nobody is looking at me I'm
like it don't look at me - look at me -
look at me here's the thing these are
anxious and shitty as well they're going
through the oh [ __ ] so if you can make
them concentrate on their own [ __ ] more
than you do you ever feel like on the
train like people are trying too hard
not to talk to each other yeah where
it's always this thing of like like it's
like they're like yeah you can't just
[ __ ] talk to someone on the goddamn
train you know it's like I people are
just super autistic nowadays they don't
have social skills yeah it's like I
wanna what I can't [ __ ] talk to
the grocery store like someone at a
grocery store you have to be silent I
have enough right now like wouldn't it
be better for everyone if we just had a
conversation yeah yeah but you're busy
looking tough and like I'm gonna I can't
be hurt by you I don't I don't like how
I can't I wish I feel like I wish yeah
don't you think you wish you could talk
to people you know yeah but I think
maybe it's good because we're not
healthy right now so it's just like like
do you ever feel like like I wish I
would like it better like I had more of
a neighbor
yeah like you actually got to know
people that were around you straight
you're whistling yeah like if you see
someone on the train more than once
you can still be like hey from the you
know we're on these trains so much we
don't know why we're doing it we're
angry so we don't want to talk to you I
will yeah it's it's weird it's a culture
if we were fighting world war two
together uh-huh we would be so friendly
to each other another subway like oh hey
you're doing the rivets I'm [ __ ] yeah
pipe bombs so we just don't have a
purpose and we need to figure one out
instead of just being like this is how
it is let's just try and shake the right
hand I know I'm a Republican why you
giving me [ __ ] on this one cuz I'm the
right person you hate it I'm right
Nathan I'm right I'm right about the
economy oh yeah I mean I love the
economy I'm right about the economy
abortion you're right about abortion
no it's and this is the one that gets
people oh this is a tricky one I'm right
about abortion I'm right I don't know I
don't give a [ __ ] about guns I think I
do give it are you a big gun guy like
you don't take my fire
arms kind of [ __ ] no I'm not like I
don't take your firearms kind of [ __ ]
he's messaging me podcasting here
they probably marry the mic do you want
to go back okay well would you say guns
yeah I'm with you I'm ambivalent I feel
like I just feel like just sort of a
cool thing shall we do that here this is
also like killing people
we're all just gonna I know I we're
always just gonna be killing each other
you know I don't think so
you think there's some way we can just
not kill it absolutely like what
technology was the most matrix coming
out of the silver technology like that
was the beginning of a movie I liked I
liked um what was it was a [ __ ] my
Ferris Bueller weird science where they
make a lady you that nerd was [ __ ] so
big back in the eighties bro that's what
it became cool to be like the thick
rimmed glasses and like the Rick Moranis
the [ __ ] prevention to make [ __ ] they
could make like a robot they it was so
they were sort of ahead of the times
with it was started in the 80s the nerd
like computer person I I wish I would
like I wish I was like a cool nerd yeah
they were saying when they invented the
trebuchet they were like the Nerds are
so cool now look they invented the
trebuchet I feel like I wish I was a
nerd like a cool nerd like hey man like
hey I know about computers like like the
point Dexter you know sorry
just like bending I feel like I'm too
dumb to be that guy yeah
I'm talking this is what he does Bobo
guarding the conversation I'm sorry give
you the time and you just okay go oh
yeah you gave me the time once I figure
done spouting off for five minutes I had
a chance to gather my thoughts yeah so
he so we're talking about the onion the
newspaper yeah yeah great people special
a big tea a tea Bowl I'm a big hard time
enjoy Special Olympics
tea and tea ball pitches perfect game oh
that's a good while a that's a good one
right yeah yeah let me finish some of
these I'm sorry what's your favorite I
didn't had like I like the one where
Andrew yang comes out of the emerges
from emerges from the ceiling or
something too because like a new
Terminator to warn people about
automation like he comes at us I can't
butchering it obvious an image it's um
it's a headline Adrian Terminator onion
google it
what if you like tried your best
remember the title and before opening
his [ __ ] mouth maybe [ __ ] know
what the hell ceiling
is describing this joke and anyways he's
like he's like the whole joke is like my
where my onions are okay is great we're
talking you never keep track on I'm
sorry if you track of my laughs know my
LPS do you ever keep track of WC Fields
no he's like an old guy you know what we
should do is have a decibel meter and
measure our sets and this accurately
scientifically figure out which tag is
the best and we should post rankings of
every mic we go to who got the most last
and who got the least and we should
become powerful with information that's
how it should do it
not like these [ __ ] tree huggers
going around trying to cheat their way
it's the worst combination of liberal
earnestness and Republican cunning
cheating they don't have the [ __ ]
work ethic as a Republican but they
don't have the good heart of the liberal
I think it's [ __ ] you have good
heart I
you know why why because it's all other
people's problem you know you're not
being like I'm giving money to the poor
oh these day with some other person take
care of these poor people you're not
[ __ ] caring for these people there is
such a thing as having a good heart baby
shower in the world tells you to be a
good person because it's an actual thing
that'll make your life better but it's
all about control it's all about forcing
people how to [ __ ] live their lives
there you taking all the money you
should avoid in but that doesn't mean
you should turn yourself into a bank
Watson what does it actually mean one
what is exploited what are you talking
about don't you think there's such a
thing as being a good person because
you're definitely not trying to like
murder me right now I understand that
there is I mean what do you think every
culture in the world has parables about
how to be a good person and how
important it is why what is a good
person to you a good person to me is
someone who treats other people kindly
and treats so what would go with what
would that mean not making other people
feel bad in a conscious way so like I
wouldn't go out of my way to make
someone feel bad if I'm gonna do
something that's gonna make other people
feel bad I would not do it or consider
it very much like what makes you people
feel bad if you call them a dumb [ __ ]
if you punch them in the face if you you
know like shove them in the subway if
you lose your boss's umbrella you know
so try not to make other people feel bad
and you'll feel better cuz then you'll
feel good cuz you're a conduit for good
and it's better to feel good than to be
a conduit for bad and feel bad there's
some basic [ __ ] sorry I'm glad you're
questioning your source code sorry so
what else did questioning your sexuality
no you know I'm straight I don't even
know if you're good there's no such
thing as being a good person no it's all
your subjective it's all whatever you
think is like just cause it's subjective
doesn't mean something I think well in
certain I think maybe we just have very
different values you know I think that
you know you're wrong I think you know
you're so wrong okay you have like you
really think what you believe is true oh
you just clearly you yeah I think you're
that I understand what point you're
trying to bring up but I just feel like
the obvious I mean that's a unique
answer it look cool I have a new
perspective but I guess I don't have the
flexible flexibility to play with being
bad just because I'm so simple but you
wanted your definition of being bad is
very vague though it's all like don't
make but you're always gonna be making
people feel bad by doing something you
know plenty of things make people feel
bad you could make fun I feel badly
whatever you know it's gonna make them
feel bad that don't do it but you ever
just feel like you're you shouldn't be
like that's what I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be the guy that thinks about myself you
should be the guy that tries not to I
feel like people aren't good to me so
why should I be good to them I'm like
screw everybody me well we are a product
of our environment I'm like I got it's a
bet but like I'm very self-centered you
should be sad that that's happening to
you but you should accept that that's
who you are you shouldn't be like yeah
I'm gonna be the best to be shitty you
should be like I'm gonna maintain my
core goodness but I have to have this
exterior porcupine shell to deal with
living in New York I just feel like I
gotta be like this oh I feel like I'm I
need to be like strong do you ever feel
like I need to be like a strong person I
think we have time I feel like I get
into my weakness too much I feel like
you are made to feel weak by your
society and your server I don't you
don't think I don't think you're you're
just blaming someone else now though
you're blaming someone else for your
fault but I can so do I have to paint
everything black everything that doesn't
stop you from like looking at it
objectively and being like yeah the
society could be a lot healthier and
mentally a lot of people are struggling
like me a lot of people are like you a
lot of people are finding it tough you
know like it's tough being on the subway
and like stare at some dudes staring you
down and making you feel like a [ __ ]
and then he's just having a bad day he's
just like fired from his job by a white
dude thank you I always feel like I
don't I don't know how to like defend
myself well you should get that maybe
that's the cause of a lot of your
anxiety do you feel that way know that
you think you could beat someone up I
would I don't think I could acknowledge
it like I don't know if I wouldn't
realize it would be happening so I think
I could about the morale somewhat
emotional component of a fire thing I
always fantasized that oh I could beat
somebody up you know like I'd be the guy
that's a really
thing to do to someone but if I had like
if he hit me I would be able to beat him
on my mom's purse and kicked my
girlfriend yeah I think I could beat him
up I think I could beat up a guy but
he'd have to be a weak guy though like I
think I would have to attack him first
[Music]
start a week no I don't think so well I
mean the mic is started at 10:00 9:45
and we could go catch the tail end of it
right now
yeah I don't want to have to get up you
don't want to go up again no you
shouldn't then you'd feel like you it
looks like you really don't want to go
up I get this I get weird hell do you
get weird Halloween vibes like around
autumn well I feel like everything is
scare like everything is just so dark
like it's just this dark like it's just
this ugly like solemn you know it's so
much it's so like it's so like creepy
like witchcraft you know that kind of
it's like everything's so foggy you know
it's like it's about you don't know and
also this weird anxiety it's like this
weird anxiety that you don't know
whether or not to wear jacket I am NOT
permeates that emotion it's like the
whole season but it's we're like I was
born in October so I try to think of it
as this thing of like oh this is my
rebirth you know like this is my second
chance this is you in the world this is
my new 2029 mm cuz mm and you harm
a good time all right I'm sorry for
being embarrassing and your arms thank
you for being embarrassing I didn't
break it maybe your body is weird you
just have like an optical illusion going
on with your spine okay
thank you guys you can find Andrew on
Instagram Twitter and Facebook he likes
to draw pictures so requests you know
requests are gladly accepted he's a
budding artist and a comedian he's very
funny he's sort of like Andy right who's
Andy right Steven right anyways check me
out on Hans Kim comedy Instagram Twitter
Facebook I was a finalist in the Seattle
International Comedy Competition Andrew
what are your credits
I'm just fun guy to be around
I've done some open mikes I have good
sets on them sometimes open my cake I
know I do I can I can do an open mic and
what come on your open mic i want
facebook i just put my name in up if I
might friendship if you put ask me that
to be a friend I'll be your friend